I'm Andrew Hansen from Indiana
University I'm going to be talking about
matching pairs of data both
translational data and orientation frame
data
my name is Andy Hansen I am from Indiana
University I'm supposed to be retired
but I have this this incredibly
seductive thing on my desk called
Mathematica which keeps giving me into
trouble and I'm going to tell you today
about how I how I got into trouble about
a year ago when my daughter who's a
biochemist by the way from Addison was
involved in protein matching said please
explain to me the the horn our mystique
quaternion matching problem and after
speaking to a number of people here at
the last WTC i gradually worked my way
into a rather interesting set of
solutions and new problems in the
orientation matching problem so i'm
going to talk about about paired data
sets and and paired data sets i guess
you can see that are interesting for a
lot of reasons one is is that the method
I'm going to use requires quaternions
and I just happen to have written a 498
page a book on quaternions which has
just been released in print on demand
and ebook with all of the typos
corrected after 12 years so the the the
typo corrected version of visualizing
quaternion z' is available from Elsevier
more to the point for the last half
century a set of problems involving
matched objects such as what we now know
as as GPS satellite tracking matching
photographic matching in aerial
reconnaissance and more recently in of
matching a known crystallized protein to
a simulated protein to see if you did a
good job on the protein matching it's
very heavily used in bioinformatics for
that purpose and the the 3d problem is
the one that has been really used for
the problems like that for the last
little since the 50s and they
all involved numerical approximations
you can get exact algebraic solutions
but they're all basically involving
four-dimensional 4x4 matrices and if you
try to evaluate those in symbolically in
Mathematica you get pages and pages of
of symbols that are relatively
intractable in fact when I was here a
year ago I was actually having trouble
with the two-dimensional subset and I
had to get Michael trot to point me to a
technique to get me out of out of that
and it went on from there to the point
where today I'm going to tell you how I
have used quaternions and Mathematica to
produce the first I should include
usable exact algebraic solutions of the
full 3d spectra and the 4d eigen spectra
and extensions to 3-d and 4-d
orientation frames few caveats of course
there are algebraic formulas of the
singular value decomposition and eigen
value in in Mathematica will produce
both numeric numerical and algebraic
output but they are hugely complex in
fact I tried the the four-dimensional
problem for the single singular value
decomposition and I wound up with nine
gigabytes of symbols so the the context
into which I am diving here is I'm
starting out with nine gigabytes of
symbols from evaluating one of the
standard ways of solving this type of
optimization problem and I am going to
show you one line I'm going to show you
a one-line solution there is absolutely
no obstacle for felix klein to have
discovered this formula if he did I have
not seen it no one I know is not no one
that I know has seen it and if anyone in
this room knows of a place where felix
klein or someone in the 19th century
wrote down this formula i would be
thrilled to find out about it because
that's only a third of what i done
and so it's I'm not I'm not scared of
having discovering it
because there's more to do nevertheless
I'd certainly love to know if there is
such a thing because I have actually
made extensions to the orientation frame
problems which are actually even better
adapted to quaternions than the spatial
problem that I will talk about now go
the right way so the the basic problem
of the root-mean-square deviation
masking problem is you begin with a set
of input data and our firfer exist for
example to a set of protein carbon alpha
locations in the PDB database that's a
good example of a reference data set
which we'll call Y that's traditional in
the literature and and one or more maybe
you know if you if you've done a
thousand protein simulations a thousand
things that are supposed to look like
the thing in the PD database but you're
not sure if it does so the question is
how do you match your test data to see
if it looks like the reference data and
the task becomes to pick a single
rotation matrix that minimizes this
object that is that is you start out
with the the sums of the squares of the
distances between the the two different
data sets you apply one single global
rotation to each element of the test
data set and you want to find out what
rotation matches those it is assumed to
start with that you have aligned the
centers of mass that's traditional in
this problem and then you go on from
there we will refine that the the the
problem from a maximization from the
minimization problem for the rmsd to
drop some constants and turn it into a
an identical problem up to constants
which i call the the cross term measure
delta and instead of minimizing the rmsd
we will maximize delta now look and see
what the structure of Delta is if this
is true for any dimension this this have
no particular dimensional dependence
until we get into the quaternion part of
it you you wind up with the the rotation
operating on the on the
data dotted into the reference data and
so that why in terms of multiplication
moves over to the left so this turns
into essentially a trace of the rotation
matrix times what's may be known as the
cross covariance met cross covariance
matrix and that has as it has X X on the
on the left part and Y on the right part
that's that's a matrix that's not
symmetric very definitely not symmetric
and so the raw form of the rmsd
optimization task is to find the global
rotation matrix r that minimizes that
trace off there so far okay
now what what what it looks like and
this is just a two-dimensional sample so
if you start out with the reference data
in red and then a typical sort of
simulated noisy data set like a protein
simulation would give you the blue
points as your test data and then this
is kind of where you start this is this
was where my simulation starts and then
I apply a global rotation leaving the
red points the the reference data where
they are and you can see that that these
red lines between the starting point and
the reference and the rotation of the of
the test data are now the individual
pieces of the norm of X minus y okay so
what we're doing is we're summing the
squares of all of the red lines that is
the the intuition of what is going on
here and what we can see let's see if I
can do this right you can actually you
can actually do this let's see this
should be bigger listen to me yeah okay
there we go okay so this is this is just
an example of how this works
you
you take over take a an individual
rotation matrix and you simply rotate
the rotation matrix and the cost the
whole score the the Delta is the blue
curve as I change the rotation matrix
well there's the after them overshoot
and it gets worse so that is the problem
the problem is to find that point in the
space of objects okay so that's our
objective so what I'm going to talk
about now is the a a quaternion version
of the 3d permanent version what I just
showed you as an example in two
dimensions that's very simple and the
interesting thing about this problem is
that it it was discovered independently
in three different literature's
photogrammetry
satellite matching a whole bunch of
literature from from NASA research
centers and and and proteomics and none
of the four papers that I found that
claim to be original sites the other
over a period of 50 years again and
again and again and again I got
acquainted with this when I was working
at the Stanford Research Institute in
the artificial intelligence Center with
a consortium of universities working on
machine vision and one of my colleagues
Berthold Horne that retired for MIT one
of the grand old men of robotics and
machine vision it was one of those four
papers and I knew of his work since
since the 80s but but there was another
paper that preceded his that he didn't
even know about and several papers that
followed that referred to neither the
preceding paper and nor Berthold horns
the method that these four papers use
reduces the 3d matching problem which in
fact can be solved in any dimension by
singular value decomposition which can
be shown through an argument by fellow
named cop's kab SC H is equivalent to
minimizing a 4b Gnaeus norm for the
Bertha matrix
our equivalent the svv and and the the
Frobenius norm are connected minimize
minimizing the 4b me stormer are
connected what horn and the other folks
did was to change the 3d problem to a
four dimensional linear algebra problem
involving a quaternion eigenvalue and
that particular problem is easy to solve
by Newton's method and that is the
problem that has that is the method that
has been used with the criterion
minimization for the last half century
I'm going to show how to exploit
quaternions in Mathematica to solve this
what is in principle a very difficult
Court cubic or quartic depending upon
which task I'm doing algebraic problem
okay the problem is cluttered here's how
it works I started out with just a few
basic facts about quaternions it's it's
a point on a three sphere in
4-dimensional including in space it is a
four vector with norm one it abates a
multiplication rule and the
multiplication rule has has the property
that it is non commutative and because
it's non commutative it turns out to be
equivalent to multiplying su two
matrices by su two matrices su 2 is the
covering group of the so3 rotation space
so one can construct a bilinear product
of quadratic quadratic form and
quadrillions that produces the the
rotation matrix and if you replace R of
Q in the trace of re by this matrix you
can simply pull out a column of
quaternion z-- on the left and a column
of quaternions on the right so it
translates this into it translates the
trace into a quadratic form and the
maximum eigen value of this since Q is
equal to 1 is the maximum possible value
of this
the matrix that appears itself appears
because of that funny little non
commuting way in which quaternion is
multiplied this so they grouped together
in strange ways when you break out the Q
left and Q right this is the way they
break out it's a non-trivial traceless
combination of the data matrix YZ and
just as a footnote I will not have time
as I only have ten minutes left to tell
you about this but I've also solved this
whole thing for a four dimensional
problem in which this matrix has no
constraints at all because trace 'fl and
non symmetric so what we do is we just
look at the eigenvalue problem itself
take that matrix m with the XX plus c u
YY plus c with easy Z's and evaluate its
determined in two ways one is as a power
Series in the coefficients in E so this
is linear equality cubic and that's the
determinant of Arctic in the data but it
also can be written as the product of
the eigenvalues themselves where we're
looking for the maximum eigen value
epsilon this is these are essentially
equivalent polynomials E and E and what
you can do then is to observe that the
polynomials are just numbers because E
comes from the specific locations in
space I I resolved the previous set of
two equations to eliminate the the
variable the little e and I see that the
number E the numbers P sub I of E are
each a particular polynomial in V
solutions therefore our task is to
invert this equation to find the
eigenvalues again you can do this just
by typing into Mathematica and you get
kilobytes megabytes gigabytes depending
upon the particular variant of the
problem if you plug it all back into the
equations I have the the eigenvalues are
now replaced by the XY z-- and Z's of
which they are linear combinations of
square roots so one of the things I've
done here is I've essentially reduced
the order of the thing that has to be
solved by the but by the by the sole
function so so if you now plug these
equations in to solve remember the trace
is zero so p1 is zero it gives you six
sets of solutions that have a very
strange structure the first elements are
all relatively simple and and the other
two elements of each of the solutions
fill pages and pages of absolutely
incomprehensible algebra you run
you look at it you go and simplify on it
you take a piece of it run simplify on
it nothing you do works trust me nothing
but there's a property you look at one
of the short ones and it's it's not too
bad actually it has a fairly simple
structure and the question is what's the
relationship of that structure to
everything else well what happens is if
you plug in random numbers you find that
each of the short things has a
corresponding identical number in the 30
kilobyte things so they're all the same
30 kilobyte things simplify in another
sector of the solutions to the other
things you can put it together like a
jigsaw puzzle and find the algebraic
solutions all in the simple one-page
form that helps a lot so if you if u s--
now stare at those expressions it turns
out that that all of those expressions
break up into into into X Y and P of
this exact same form basically R cosine
minus P 2 where the cosines correspond
to the real parts of the cube roots of
minus 1 that's all there is the entire
structure of this linear algebra problem
involves the three cube roots of minus 1
the more complicated one the
four-dimensional one it's it's the
complex roots because they're complex
roots in four dimensions non symmetric
and so and so these what these wind up
being
e to the I to pi/8 K over three in the
real case with a symmetric case
everything is real and so these are all
basically real real numbers with the
plus 0 minus 2 pi out 2 PI over 3 plus 2
PI over 3 and the little functions that
I have there are extremely simple just
just just a few lines in P 2 P 3 and P 4
you plug those into this and you have
not only your your your eigenvectors but
you have them in order if you choose the
right order of the little cosines on the
previous page that is your maximum
eigenvalue the problem is solved you can
pull out the the eigenvectors just just
by solving this equation by plugging
plugging in epsilon 1 for that variable
e you have to be a little bit careful if
if M has a diagonal element and this is
the point at which I can actually spend
maybe 2 minutes running running a demo
let me just give the summary then I'll
run the demo so the solution I just
showed you is unknown to the best of my
knowledge it might be there in the in
the 19th century literature I haven't
seen it all the previous 20th century
literature solves these numerically
using Newton's using Newton's method for
a single maximum a quatrain eigenvalue
giving the quaternion solution for the
optimal alignment of the rmsd problem
using similar methods I have solved the
3d frame alignment problem where for
example each protein instead of a
position is a list of the orientation
frames of the amino acids and I've
solved it in addition for four
dimensions which is an extension to a
pair of quaternions a non equal
quaternions bracketing a generalized M
function ok so I have a couple of
minutes left let me come down to here ok
so here is an example of a three
dimensional data set
so this is this is and you can sort of
see it's been rotated around that course
even hole in the middle that's a
three-dimensional data set here is
either is the the alignment moving from
out of alignment to in alignment using
using the optimal solution and the last
thing I want to do oh yeah here's and
here's an entire set so here a thousand
different data sets so I have I have
pulled up a thousand different data sets
and what I'm gonna do is I am going to
create the list of eigen value so you
can see that that's it says map eigen
values onto onto the matrices do that in
value eight no hold on will happen shift
return there okay and then I'm going to
do it with my function and then this is
it this is the entire function that we
evaluated let's compare
let's compare the lists ok so there's
there's the there from from the from
Mathematica running running list of
eigen values these are the list of
maximum in order doggin values and here
is the comparable list from the
algebraic form and now I'm gonna take
all 1000 elements of the eigen value
list I am going to subtract them I'm
going to tell you them and chop them and
it's zero thousand two within within 10
to the minus 15 every single one of the
algebraic ones matches the algebraic set
thank you very much
[Applause]